thank you
[Music]
are you guys familiar with Art Basel
yeah Miami oh yeah yeah am I shaking
right no it's not basil or basil I
specifically looked up people saying it
to make sure I was saying it right and
they're saying Art Basel all right what
about it yeah so it's in Miami no yeah
it sounds fancy yeah how confident I am
in it
I heard about it kind of know what it
was a visual representation
the butter first and then put strawberry
on
[Laughter]
so check this out look at this picture
of these people crowded around this ATM
what do you think's got them so
interesting oh I saw that [ __ ] yeah
that's crazy
oh I know I know it's like where they
try to get a high score for having the
most money in their account yeah
so like pretty much it's it's pretty
much like an art attraction but it's a
real ATM that when you use it you go on
a leaderboard above it showing how much
money you have in your checking whoa
that's [ __ ] funny so everybody's just
staring and looking at it so it's like a
dick measuring contest it looks like
this look they take your photo as you
like it just shows you the balance and
it shows your balance yeah there's a
thing about this with credit card points
out there too people have competitions
about who has more credit card points oh
Point yeah that's pretty fun because you
can get free flights and stuff I love
credit card points the highest score
because that's not well let's see if
you're impressed they'll judge by your
face okay so the average uh that most
people had was between 10 and 20K
like imagine if you're gonna do this you
would try to get like some yeah wow
that's the average for all my funds
unless you're trying to troll and put
like a thousand for the people that are
doing it for the people going oh yeah
sample of the population yeah because I
was like damn that's a lot you're gonna
do it you're not gonna be the one that
has eight dollars in there which is sad
if you're funny but if I was in the
average of like just ten thousand I'd be
like I'm not doing this yeah
because that means that you thought you
were tight and you weren't that tight
yeah
it's because you read news articles
whether like the average American can't
afford a two thousand dollar emergency
you're like I'm gonna show these
[ __ ]
quite a bit of people that had straight
up zero or close to zero that's tight do
they make it on the leaderboard at all
or is it they just kind of like you'll
see that like like a golf score
leaderboard with like lowest score one
yeah
so the negatives because they need the
most help yeah
is that why rich people like golf
because it's the opposite of what
they're used to it's like you don't want
the most points I mean I already have a
lot of that okay yeah I'm trying to get
less this keeps me humble yeah before I
show what the highest score was what's a
good excuse for why like what do you
think people are saying with the like
you know people can be like oh that's
just my checking for spending for food
and whatever like yeah what do you think
people are saying to be like Ah that's
that's not my real account like what
excuses are popular you should see my
crypto wall that's a good one yeah this
is my liquid
you should see my wife's
that's good I was like I got a
restaurant though
that's the main are you is this an
example are you oh mostly tied up in the
restaurant business yeah yeah basically
it's like it's like they just talk about
oh well it's all stuck in assets yeah
it's all in real estate well you keep
motivating cash because you don't want
to give it to the man yeah
it's like don't ask me how much gme I
have
what's what look at this so there's
number 32 that's the ranking this is
number one so based on her reaction this
is who had the most money at Art Basel
oh okay okay yeah I mean like in your
checking account that's not FDIC insured
like I wouldn't do that I would separate
250. no it's like three mil the number
one you see is three mil no no no no the
person here
I think it's I think they raised it a
little bit I used to be 100K okay so
they raised it to 250. what do you think
what do you think they look like this
person three mil oh I don't know the
first the first one I think the first
one was like a a young looking guy right
he's a kind he's kind of a Steve
[Laughter]
damn three million that's pretty cool
but yeah that's don't keep that in your
checking account who's number two just
to do this
on this picture you want to see who's
number two or what if that is his
checking and his savings is even crazy
no does he even have a savings like
Ryan's account you know yeah
spread all over the place you better go
to basil oh Sam
Sam I have a confession I don't have a I
don't have a savings account at all it's
a waste is it a waste yeah the interest
is so small that I mean it should just
be a holding ground until you can
transfer it into other assets I don't
even use one how many bank accounts do
you have like just like eight
[Laughter]
what we're gonna fix this inflation
thing
let me figure out in a couple years no
when I used to bank with Washington
Mutual I had a savings and a checking
and then when Chase took it over
something happened and then I forgot
what happened but I only you have a
checking account left when I signed up
for a savings account I got five percent
interest and then that was back in 2010
five percent and then each year they
went down it was online savings and it
was kind of new like because Allah it
was Ally and um I think HSBC was the
other one that was competing for five
percent so I had it in HSBC and it was
five percent and then they went to four
percent and then Ally was still at five
so I transferred to Ally and then they
just went down five percent each year
and now it's at point five percent wow
you know what 20. I got this [ __ ] in the
mail and it was like oh congratulations
you could be getting point zero five
percent in your savings account and I
was like remember
how [ __ ] stupid do you think that's
like not even a percent it's point zero
five percent that makes me want to
scream at the envelope [ __ ]
you do one with credit card
Yeah the more debt you have the more
savings you get oh yeah
the sad thing is if if you're in the
same so that's like an Art Basel right
what if you're like a few boots away
trying to sell art and you're like none
of these [ __ ] people can afford this
[ __ ] you're number 58 get out of here
man don't even look at some of those
pains are like uh five six figures damn
super expensive it's your whole checking
account that's a funny thing to
basically be in a place where you're
trying to sell and you can see how much
money people have to spend it's kind of
funny I love this kind of art though I
love this [ __ ] oh yeah and installation
art it also makes a toilet flushing
sound as you're waiting for your uh
number
interesting touch
what flavor
what flavor of toilet no I'm just saying
probably because you're a piece of [ __ ]
if you're doing that you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah it is a dick
I feel like some Miami nightlife [ __ ] I
always I always thought it would be a
funny prank to um like have an ATM
machine or like wait like at 7-Eleven
where you pay with your card to have the
[ __ ] thing be like a speak and spell
when you put your PIN so it goes five
nine two three
oh what the [ __ ] man oh this guy's like
what was that say it again
that'd be such a funny prank my [ __ ]
voice is so scary what's crazy is does
it matter how good art is any like
installation that Taps into your natural
narcissistic Tendencies will always win
yeah it's like I bet if you go to the
craziest art show and then one of them
is just the mirror and you have like a
counter of who looked at this art and
how many people have looked at the
mirror oh wow
everybody's all about look at me March
Basel are you an artist dude
hey cut that out
get that [ __ ] out and then like do the
gallery of mirrors yeah they should have
a eye tracker track the mirror have a
counter have a eye tracker on the arch
have a counter and then charge the
mirror more in the [ __ ] all
right yeah that's good data yeah and the
actual art is the eye tracker the
patent for that but that's how you sell
some rich [ __ ] I'm here yeah and then
like I guess I gotta pay five million
for this mirror it's a [ __ ] ass that's
a good point
okay so this is what was showing at the
gallery there was this one article we
did on JK a long time ago where it was
like a restaurant that if you could fit
through these bars then you could eat
for free
it's like a discount for each space yeah
yeah
that's a pretty clever idea so many
people needed to eat free well I think
it uh more discounting things as in
they're not gonna eat that much anyway
their stomachs are all small yeah like
you have to pay more the bigger you are
or something that makes sense yeah oh
wow any competitive eaters are small
jeez the bit you are the more food you
order geez that's not true packing some
food and they're [ __ ] tiny that's you
that's true yeah so do you put on the
jam after the butter
it doesn't work like that
[Music]